Speaker 1: Donald Trump appeared yesterday
on the Chris Stegall podcast.
I have no idea what that is, but these are
the sorts of interviews that the failed former
president is now relegated to doing.
Trump's brain broke it.
It acutely broke it almost made a noise like
a clanking noise when it broke.
That's a joke.
Trump repeating the now widely debunked conspiracy
theories about the attacker of Paul Pelosi.
Trump saying that he once made rough statements
on Jewish.
What does that mean?
I have no idea what the hell this guy is talking
about.
Look at the breakdown of this man's brain,
starting with the first clip Trump asked about
the assault on Paul Pelosi.
Listen to what Trump said.
Speaker 3: How do you read what's happened
in the Pelosi household in San Francisco over
the weekend?
Speaker 1: By the way, why do all of these
right wingers have the Alex Jones voice.
Speaker 3: Pac-Man's a.
Speaker 1: Loser?
AI Why do they all talk like Alex Jones topic
for a different day?
Speaker 3: Well, it's weird things going on
in that household in the last couple of weeks.
You know, like probably you and I are better
not talking about it, but that less, it seems,
was broken from the inside to the out lie.
And you know, that was so it wasn't a break
in.
It was a break out.
I don't know.
You know, you hear the same things I do.
Yeah.
The 911 tape seems to suggest that the that
he knew the identity of the guy.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's a that's a lot of bad stuff.
I'm not a fan of Nancy Pelosi, but what's
going on there is very sad.
Yeah, I just it seems to me there would be
security evidence of this.
There just seems to be a lot of this story
with what are they safe to say?
This is, I think, more than the traffic accidents,
it looks like to me, like the traffic light
on Republicans or user.
I mean, how absurd.
Clearly, this was a deranged man.
We know that much.
Yeah, it's the whole thing is crazy.
I mean, if there's even a little bit of truth
to what's being said, it's crazy.
But is the window was broken in and it was
strange that the cops were standing there
practically.
They didn't from the moment it all took place.
Speaker 1: So, listen, Trump repeated these
claims yesterday, November 1st, after we already
had information about all of these claims.
The attacker himself confirmed all of what
we now know to be true.
The cops didn't just stand there.
They very quickly found the guy.
The glass was not broken from the inside out.
Yes, there were pieces of glass on the outside.
Imagine taking a hammer to a glass window.
Every time you pull it back towards you to
hammer it again, you put a little bit of glass
out.
It's not a big shock that there was glass
on the outside.
Pelosi didn't say, I know the guy.
It appears as though in order to keep the
guy calm or while on the phone with 911, he
said something like My friend here.
But he did not literally mean I know the guy.
The guy is known to me.
The attacker already said he had had no previous
contact with Pelosi.
Pelosi was in his underwear because he sleeps
in his underwear.
And it was two in the morning.
There were security cameras that recorded
every single one of these lies already debunked.
But this is nothing.
Then during the Chris Stegall interview, they
get to the topic of Kanye West and Trump says.
He made rough statements on Jewish.
I. I know what you're saying.
David, are you.
Are you missing a word there?
What do you mean?
What?
Listen.
Speaker 3: Do you think Kanye West is getting
a fair shake?
I always thought after he aligned with you,
even for a while, he was a marked man, no
matter what he said or done, since he you
know, he's been on the Tucker Carlson shows.
You know, how do you read Kanye West these
days?
Well, I was very honored when I was, because
I didn't know him that well.
But I like him.
I always get along with him very well.
And I was very honored in a sense, because
he you know, he said all those great things
about me on Tucker Carlson.
Uh.
Speaker 1: By the way, that's what matters.
If he said good things about Trump, Trump's
going to defend him.
Speaker 3: Made some statements.
Rough statements on Jewish.
Speaker 1: Rough statements on Jewish.
I might once made rough statements on an apple.
I was sitting on the apple.
It was weird.
Speaker 3: You heard them and you know that.
Well, yes.
And they're saying that that was the reason.
So that you ask, well, would it have been
the same thing if it didn't say all those
good things about Trump?
You know, you just don't know.
Yeah, he'll be fine.
I think he'll be fine.
Yeah.
He's a very different kind of a guy.
Yes.
And it was very interesting to hear him on
Tucker Carlson, because, you know, you never
hear him in long sentences.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: They also cut out a bunch of anti-Semitic
stuff from the Tucker interview, too.
Speaker 3: He was actually very sharp and
very, very smart.
I was I was impressed by a lot of what he
said when he talked about life.
He talked about health.
These are things that he feels the black community
is being lied to about the things he does.
He feels it.
Speaker 1: And and it's all about what have
you done for me lately?
Kanye has praised Trump.
So Trump's because they listen.
He made rough statements on Jewish, whatever
that means.
But he's pretty brilliant.
I like a lot of the things he said.
Trump confirms he won't go back to Twitter
in the context of his own platform.
Speaker 3: Trump Censure.
Yeah, if I go on there, what would happen
to truth?
I don't know.
You know, I, I don't know.
But at the edges, I'm not doing it right.
I won't go back on and but I find truth to
be much better.
It's smarter, it's friendlier and also can
be very nasty.
Yeah.
Oh, yes.
Especially if they get against you a little
bit.
Even your own people, if they disagree with
something you did, they get nasty.
Speaker 1: Trump is talking about vaccines
there.
Speaker 3: Yeah, we got some smart ones, but
it's it's tremendous.
And it was number one for the last couple
of weeks.
It's incredible.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So Donald Trump, his own platform, which he
often gets the name wrong of.
Speaker 3: Trump Central.
Speaker 1: He says he's sticking with truth
and not going back on Twitter.
And lastly, Trump playing with these supply
chain games.
Remember when Trump used to love to say the
cupboards were bare and all this different
stuff?
Now he's saying there's no turkeys.
Speaker 3: This shouldn't be in this country.
And I can't help but feel like it's purposeful.
Sir.
Sir, is that your read?
Well, it's certainly a terrible thing and
it certainly shouldn't be.
And supply chain shouldn't be in this country
either.
I mean, pure, you know, just basic supply
chain.
Now, I understand you can't get turkey.
Speaker 1: You can't get turkey.
Now, Trump understands, folks, listen, this
interview was on November 1st.
Who is buying a turkey on November 1st for
a November 24th Thanksgiving now?
Sure.
If you've got a huge freezer or something,
I know some people will buy the turkey on
November 1st.
Every place I'm seeing is scheduling the turkey
pickups for like Monday, Tuesday and Wednesday
of Thanksgiving week.
That's number one.
And then number two, I've just been to two
different grocery stores this week.
They're filled with turkeys.
There's turkeys bursting out of everywhere.
I tried to get avocados.
There were turkeys there.
I tried to get you know, I tried to get whatever.
Anyway, there's turkeys everywhere at this
point in time.
Trump relegated to completely frothing at
the mouth, friendly interviews on podcasts.
No one's ever heard of Chris Stegall and he
still doesn't make any sense.
Let's keep fighting this right wing nut tree
by growing progressive, independent media
as far as we can.
If you are watching these clips on YouTube
and you were not subscribed, please hit that
subscribe button.
I know many of you say, David, sir, I see
all your clips.
I don't need to subscribe.
Do me the favor, because there's almost 3
million of you who watch the clips but don't
subscribe.
If we were to get to 2 million YouTube subscribers,
it would be an accomplishment held only by
the Young Turks in the progressive media space.
Help us get there.
Hit that subscribe button.
I'll give you an update on our progress next
week.